would you be surprised if I told you
most people still haven't logged on to
Chad gbt and have not even used it one
time most people Mr Pat that's not even
possible I'm hosting an event at the
Boca resort with 230 entrepreneurs these
are guys that are doing a million to 200
million dollars per year these are
business guys 100 employees 50 employees
300 employees I said raise your hand if
you've never used Chad gbt people raise
their hands I said stand up they stood
up 80 of the room stood up then the
other 20 I said those of you guys that
are using it regularly give us ideas on
what you're doing and everybody was
blown away today I'm going to give you
seven ways you can use AI to speed up
the growth of your business if you get
value at the end of the video you give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it Point
number one risk and legal so they did a
crazy experiment taking a group of top
lawyers competing against AI gave them
four hours to review documents to see
which one of them after reviewing it
would have the highest success ratio of
how much information they retain well
the law lawyers took 92 minutes and AI
you know how long it took 26 seconds
then they took the test you know with
the success ratio on the test was the
lawyers got an 85 success ratio and AI
95 lawyers can't even directly compete
with AI anymore so how are people using
AI for risk and legal here's what
they're doing it can help answer complex
questions scanning vast amounts of legal
documentation drafting reviewing annual
reports identifying Clauses within
contracts and compared with other
documents and a matter of fact recently
according to statista 58 believe using
AI allows for more consistent decision
making in a significantly shorter time
frame so if you're not using AI for that
that's one of the ways to leverage AI
number two is customer service which is
I mean you've been to many different
websites when the thing pops up on the
bottom right you're like oh okay here's
a question that they want to ask you and
some people say well does that even
really work or not here's what it comes
down to in my business I sold Insurance
I've sold a lot of different products
over the years but I have an FAQ real
estate has an FAQ mortgages has an FAQ
every business has an FAQ but for the
most part if you ask somebody give me
the most common questions people ask and
they'll say these are the 90 of the time
it's these five questions perfect AI
knows the answer to those five questions
and it'll respond back to the customers
asking those questions based on a
chatbot that they have and according to
Salesforce 23 of customer service
companies are currently using Ai and on
top of that here's what IBM just said
using AI Bots the chat Bots can reduce
your customer service costs by as much
as 30 percent so if you're not using it
right now this is one of the easiest way
to save some money number three is
training and getting content out of it
so if you look at Chad gbt there's a
couple different things that people are
doing I know right now thousands of
people that are making Tick Tock videos
by simply asking Chad gbt what are 10
topics for finance that's going viral
right now for me to create that works
very well on Tick Tock and it'll give
you boom boom boom give me 10 scripts on
financial Wars that are going viral on
Tick Tock or video for me to make it'll
give it to you what are top 10 Common
objections that a realtor gets when
selling a home to a luxury Community
million dollars above creating meal
plans that does it for you it doesn't
matter what it is it can be your
personal trainer if I want to tone up
and lose 100 pounds I'm 220 pounds right
now you know what do I need to take away
from my diet to be able to reduce my
body fat percentage you can pretty much
talk to this thing it'll give it to you
but that's the point with training if
you're somebody that's training your
guys managers seven mistakes managers
make when trying to address conflict
gives it to you again I can go on and on
and on but the whole point is a recent
statistic that came out from employees
is 49 of employees working on companies
want to be trained on how to use Ai and
they don't this is one of the things
that you can start testing chat gbt to
help you out with that a lot of people
are using today there's this one stat
that's going around that's got a lot of
people concerned saying 20 of all jobs
are going to be replaced in the next
five years by Ai and people are reacting
to it in two different ways one they're
panicking doing nothing about it two
people are taking courses to learn on
how how to get better at AI one of the
ways people are doing it is through
udemy udemy has over 200 courses to
choose from 100 specific on AI one of
them that they have with 23 000 reviews
on udemy is called artificial
intelligence A through Z 2023 built an
AI with Chad gbt4 if you're somebody
that doesn't know that much about AI
That's running a business you're in a
very competitive environment you may
want to take this course on udemy or
others and learn for yourself on how to
use AI to accelerate your success of
your business having said that there's a
link below you can click on to learn
about these courses and get a discount
as a value tenor so if you haven't yet
started click on the link below go to
udemy start your courses now number four
you can use AI for data and by the way
for me some of the best hires I've ever
made is anybody that's been a business
analyst on Predictive Analytics the data
they give me I can sit there and look at
and say you know what this pattern I'm
seeing we're not doing this good on this
way I'd like to be able to make
projections better on this thing here
according to Forbes the most recent
research in indicates that a combination
of AI and big data can automate nearly
80 percent of all physical work 70 of
data processing work and 64 percent of
data collection tasks so think about if
it gathers the Intel and it says to you
what would it be worth you to know that
your best selling hour of the week is
Thursdays at 4 28. from 4 to 5 is your
best out well you can get that kind of
data right what would it be worth you
for you to know you know what months you
do best or what hours you do best or
your audience where it's coming from and
it does it all for you automatically
because it's AI again unfortunately this
takes jobs away from a lot of people
today that are doing Predictive
Analytics because AI is going to do that
job for them but you may as well start
using it because this is not going away
number five sales and marketing remember
how I explained to your point number two
was around customer service how you can
use a chat bot to answer the questions
which is more like reactive is there any
questions I can answer to you yes what
about this you can do this what about
that you can do that what about this you
can do that have I been able to answer
all your questions for you yes and it
goes away right now imagine on the sales
and marketing side for AI this thing can
now go and see when you're on a page
that you're clicking on what you're
clicking prompts there's interest in
this product but you haven't bought yet
and asks you a more specific question
because it's proactive to say I notice
you're looking at an SUV here is there
any specific color you were looking for
I'm looking for a white one great you
know what is the best number to get a
hold of you to contact you so we can
give you more answers to your questions
so the customer service is reactive the
sales and marketing AI that they're
creating is now proactive takes the
customer off and somebody can call to
set them up so the closers can close so
they're also using that AI for sales and
marketing size nowadays that's
essentially taking the setter out in the
sales process and this sets you up for
somebody to close the deal and matter of
fact according to a Harvard Business
Review using AI in this area increases
leads by more than 50 percent and
reduces call Time by 60 to 70 percent
because a lot of that has already been
addressed by AI this next one's kind of
weird because it's copywriting and SEO
optimizers which by the way a lot of the
copywriters you're hiring right now and
they're working for you and you're
thinking they're spending hours writing
they're not they're actually using Chad
gbt because they're able to take 20
customers that they can manage where it
used to be four because they were
actually manually writing so they're
generating more income so you if you're
able to understand how to use Chad gbt
you don't necessarily need a copywriter
you can literally ask I need 10 titles
for a video to give it to you you can
ask give me five examples of a great
mission statement for a real estate
company targeting middle income families
and wanting to have their dreams become
a reality for first-time homeowners boom
here's all these mission statements
anyways you can use Chad gbt for so many
different ways for copywriters and save
yourself 60 70 80 000 per year for
copywriter because AI does that for you
this last one you're probably already
using and you may not even be aware of
it but you can even take it to a whole
different level which is automation you
can create rules for emails you get an
email and somebody says something you
can create different rules on how to
respond if they say a question that's
being asked about this respond back with
the following answer and send this
brochure to them or link to a video or
you know I'm gonna CC my assistant here
so you can get a time to get on the
calendar with you and all of that can be
automated with different rules that you
create you know an answer within five
minutes don't answer right off the bat
dude within nine minutes listen there's
so many different things you can do with
the automation side and some of us are
going through right now on Facebook say
you have a group and a lead comes in and
they have a phone number it can
automatically be automated to go into
HubSpot where somebody from sales again
this is something you need to take a
course to learn more about what's going
on with AI because based on the meeting
I had this last week at Boca Resort and
I asked this question all I realize is
there's not enough people using AI right
now by the way again the community that
says well I'm scared because of what
it's going to do it's been around for a
while it's just accelerating and if you
don't trust me your competitors are
using AI for some of you that have no
clue what Chad gbt is and who started
who's behind it why is musk's name being
thrown around and why is musk so worried
about it today click on a link here
above I made a video explaining the
history behind chat gbt having said that
if you got value from the video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye-bye
foreign